envie d'aller visiter le quartier le
plus cool en main cherchez pas c'est ici
avant la
on
mile end alex et quartiers les plus cool
au monde selon moritz made by on est
dans un des quartiers les plus cools
ressemble pas à grand chose
c'est très authentique l'important c'est
cool a lancé demandé on va essayer de
trouver la réponse est négative avec les
gens qui vit ici depuis l'enfance par
bonjour oui le foot ça va bien alors ici
on est dans le mile end le quartier le
plus cool au monde que c'est encore une
fois comment la série mancelle
à la mode branchée la cantine et de
prévoir révéler ses secrets
et ça c'est des premiers lieux coup-là
by lm c'est dieu qui a capitalisé de
l'époque ce n'était vraiment un cru qui
multiplie aps
mais maintenant il ya des musiciens des
écrivains qui passe le temps là mais
aussi
la vieille qui se veut dire la vie où on
va toujours ses vieux les surinamiens
qui vient tous les jours pendant
qu'après on a besoin de ça pour que ça
soit ok on va me fais ok alors sa tion
des feux prix qui va tout à fait dans le
ton à la partie du charme de montréal du
coup levé oui oui oui ça c'est
typiquement montréalais
oh
une douzaine de ces armes je croisais
des touristes chez moi même j'ai acheté
ma gueule parce que selon louis travail
ça c'est cool
en fait la firme explique qu'il a servi
à tobago ça que ça n'a pas changé c'est
ça que bergman 50 balais youtube et
gamal jugés si on avait la balle à bas
les usines de textile partout pam ici
une usine de textile qui est l'un des
premiers centres artistiques ont créé en
on y va si on prend l'exemple du
quartier manex alors il ya dix ans aux 8
9 ans quand c'est un seul ici il n'y
avait rien dans le quartier il ya
maintenant il ya quand même des lieux où
on peut aller après après le travail
faire un 5 à 7 où on peut fréquenter les
endroits plate de pas la réplique à
paris qu'à la cellule cools pour nous
parce que c'est sympa de pouvoir rester
dans la partie travailler
il doit manger
franchement définir ce qui est cool ou
pas c'est quand même pas évident mais on
a essayé une chose qui est sûre qu'ils
changent pas maintenant real change
c'est ce qu'on aime
l'offre culinaire pour tous leurs krstic
l'offre sportive les espaces verts et le
vélo la marche
il
prochaine capsule on va voir comment
montréalais vont lui